to avoid used to dream of finishing
school now she just wants to walk again
she lost the use of her legs after she
stepped on a mine planted by ISIL
fighters she can't leave her bed and her
brother tries to keep her comfortable
her situation hurts us so much and all
we wish is to see her standing on her
feet again
Maki Ida begs other sister and three
cousins including a nonnatus tribal
leader were also killed by ice and mines
two years ago an ISIL attack until a
berry killed four US and five Nigerian
soldiers in May the US military released
this video of a recovery operation after
28 Nigerian soldiers were killed in a
single ISIL attacks in Ladouceur
Aram nato-led there are no people in in
itis they fled because of the fighting
they started killing people in 2018 and
again this year leaders of inertia's
have been killed many other people have
lost their lives fighting between ISIL
and national and international forces
since July has led to a big increase in
people fleeing violence to nearby Aero
Atilla berry City and Miami Haase and
his wife and five children were among
them we suffer in many ways we fled our
homes and we came here we don't have a
place to live some of us did not even
have a mattress and couldn't find any
help traders here say they can no longer
continue their business because of the
violence we lift our goods and trade
lost our money and suddenly found
ourselves here with nothing the disaster
has hit all the districts of Atilla
Barre especially near the border with
Mali the UN warns that a crisis in the
Sahel region including nazir Mali and
Burkina Faso is reaching unprecedented
levels
and more than 5 million people need
humanitarian assistance the United
Nations is urging these displaced people
to enroll their children in local
schools and with violence and landmines
in their village they don't know when
they'll be able to go back
Laura Burton Manly al-jazeera